foreign
let's go to uh Dustin in Sanford Florida
what's up Dustin
hey what's up brother just hanging out
how are you doing today dude I'm doing
the exact same thing I'm running this
this scam over here called a uh YouTube
show it's awesome
[Laughter]
appreciate everything you do brother
thank you man so what's up brother how
can I help
so I've got like
50 million different changes going on in
life right now
um and just trying to I guess that's
just the season um that I'm in but the
big question
um I guess I really have with everything
um
is
um with the current transition uh
transitioning out of the military
um into civilian life and how long you
been in
uh I did uh eight and a half years
uh what was your role
um for those years
um I was uh Infantry
um and then the last half of that was uh
Aviation uh worked on uh helicopters oh
so you've seen it huh yeah man yeah uh
all the nitty-gritty stuff oh yeah yeah
and it's like
I'm at this um turning point in my life
where
for the first time I'm really getting to
make my own decisions and
I guess my the question
um is do I
aware that
um my service time has a badge of Pride
and honor whatever
or do I just
put it all behind me and just completely
ISO or honestly isolate but leave that
military
Community behind what's the what's the
impetus
what's that why you've boxed yourself
into an either or why do you feel the
need to make that call
I think a lot of it for me is
like we've just moved it you know we
just moved into a new house and you know
for the first time like I don't have to
put on the uniform every day
um and so like I've got a tough box in
the middle of my living room right now
um like filling up with
you know uniforms and stuff and I look
at that and
um
foreign
like every time I open it like my heart
starts racing yeah
why does it start racing
I think a lot of it for me is
um
just
a lot of like the mental
um
things I guess I just haven't like
processed
um
can I tell you what I think it is yeah
you've seen a lot of stuff right you've
seen a lot of
the worst of the worst
and you've seen the word good wrapped up
in some pretty messy evil and you've
seen the word evil wrapped up in like
that's not so bad right you've seen it
all
um
and when we say see it all people most
people have watched the movies and
you've seen it and experienced it and
felt it
I don't necessarily
think that's what it is
for the last eight years so let's just
say decade
you've had a purpose and a mission and a
role
and you've had people who
manicured every moment of your day
and more importantly
you fixed a helicopter
surrounded by sand and smoke and other
people had guns and they were laying
their life on the line so you could do
your job
you have an insight into what tribe and
community and friendship and loyalty
looks like that most people will never
understand
and I think this is completely me okay I
think a big part of the PTSD crisis that
we have from people returning
is we drop them off and say go make good
choices and here's some pamphlets go get
them
and it's unmooring yes they've seen hard
things but if you look at the trauma
literature people who experience hard
things in the context of loving adult
relationships do okay over time
and I think your body knows more than I
will ever know
we're about to be real real lonely we're
about to find ourselves out in the
middle of a battlefield and our team
left us and we know what that means
right
that's my guess is that you were you're
losing or you are opting out of
everything and that doesn't mean it's
the wrong thing it's actually the right
thing for you man you've put in you put
in your decade it's time it's cool
I think your body knows that is that
fair man I'm I'm I haven't come home
from combat veteran world so you could
tell me I'm off
is like
you know we've
actually said we just we just uh I got
out
um well living in Hawaii and so we're
transitioning from Hawaii and now we're
living all the way completely on the
other let's just move to the other side
of the the country we're down in Florida
now and so it's like adjusting to that
it's you know adjusting to
a new work environment a new work
community and
like
um you know trying to
make all these new adjustments into
things and trying to
can I can I like your language is that
of a car mechanic
I need to make it or or a helicopter
mechanic right I've got to make an
adjustment here I got to tighten this
rolling girder spring thing over here
and the right
foreign let me
challenge you
to not look at what's before you as a
series of knobs to turn and wrenches to
crank
for the first time in a long time you
are gonna have to feel stuff
and feeling stuff in many ways would
have got you killed the last decade and
now it's the thing that's going to keep
you alive
and it's a set of skills that you don't
have and so you're gonna have to
practice it
is that fair
definitely and I mean I'm sure I'm
trying like of course you are of course
dude you're awesome yeah of course you
are man like don't have me clowning on
you I just want to give you a different
like you're gonna you're naturally gonna
try to solve problems with the way that
you've solved problems before and you've
had the opportunity to solve problems
with bullets flying at you and with
other people with people's like dying or
dead next to you like you've had to
solve problems and so it's natural that
man all this change all this chaos all
this ah I'm going to go back to what I
know what I've been trained to do which
is to break this thing down and to
adjust
right
right and like you know I'm
do we just like last night
um had our first night of like small
groups and like trying to get plugged in
with that and and hey that's the worst
man right it's like is the worst because
the last time they sent you to basic and
y'all did push-ups and PT you'll get all
this crap together and you looked up six
months later and you were a you you were
one
and now you're sitting around with a
bunch of like Suburban dads like hey man
you know what's really tough the air
conditioning and you're like nope not
tough not tough
um and uh my lawnmower wouldn't start
that's it's Obama's fault and you're
like no no not a thing it's right so
you've got this ringside seat and the
challenge for you
is to choose and it's gonna be hard
is to choose to find community in new
places
and dude it's so fun you're holding you
30 31 30 yeah okay it's the worst it's
it's the worst
making friends as a 30 and four-year-old
it's the worst but you have to have
people in your tribe and your gang and
you are gonna have to all veterans are
have to understand that it won't be like
it was and dude
you and I both know veterans who are 55
and whenever they get together they go
back and tell stories back when they
were 19. the same as you and I both have
like yeah Bros who are high school
football heroes and they get together
and they tell the same football stories
and here's why because that's the last
time they were part of something bigger
than themselves
and the military gives you that in an
extraordinary way
and the mission before you now is I you
are going to have to opt into that it's
not going to be presented for you
and that's just a set of skills man
is that fair
yeah definitely definitely
um what you do what's your new what's
your new mission
or well played no what's your new
Mission your job will feed your mission
what is your what's your objective
um
I don't know right now I'm just trying
to uh that's it I don't even know what
your answer is you you're gonna be feel
aimless and purposeless
and when your body's untethered
then your body will ring the anxiety
alarms
and when you don't have people in your
life you don't have a gang in your
corner
um your body will ring the anxiety
alarms
and it's gonna be hard to get out of bed
you're gonna snap at your wife you're
going to just roll your eyes to some
dude is wearing loafers and no socks and
he's like let me tell you what's going
on in the world and you'll be like dude
shut up you don't know
and all of that is going to feel like
the problem that that
box full of your gear in the middle of
your living room is going to feel like
the problem and it's not
what's your mission
I think it's just um
just trying to get like reconnected like
my wife kids
um like Community around me and
everything it's just what's your mission
because I mean because I think it's a
lot of it's just been like being yeah
just being lonely right now like
foreign
yeah yeah because it's just like
I feel like at times like
you know
that
person or in a room and I'm like hey
like
let's you know talk about whatever I
never did always you know I work with a
bunch of
um veteran guys and it's like they just
it's like constantly like
oh yeah back when I was in the Army too
I'm like dude I don't want to talk about
that like it's it's exhausting it's like
I just want like
and that's like where it where it all
boils down to it's like
I feel like in One Direction like I want
to put it all like the military and
everything like behind me and and move
on
but I'm constantly surrounded by
other people that have been in that
community
and it's like I don't necessarily know
if I
want to be there you know yeah totally
and you find yourself in in the odd man
out right you're no man's land
right which is a really lonely unmooring
place to be
so I
I did I uh Jenna and Kelly let me know
this call was coming so I reached out to
two different people
one is a friend of mine and she's
actually on deployment right now
um she's wrapping up like in two months
and then another one is a close buddy of
mine who's a seal who's just rolling off
okay
and the roll-off process for them for
for him has been a quite a season and I
just asked them
that question
because I get the that question you're
asking makes sense
is this just a chapter of my life and
now I move on and I gotta start wearing
really short khaki shorts like is this
is this what's next
um or do I have to just keep like
talking about military stuff for the
rest of my life is that forever right
and do I cut this group out do I cut out
and so I'm gonna read you directly what
they wrote me is that cool yeah man they
have a better they get to I've sat with
a bajillion that's they're living it and
I have it and I want to honor their
voice okay
here's what one of them wrote
I think happiness in life is achieved
through balance so going all in or
cutting it all off probably isn't the
answer
I recommend keeping in touch with
veterans and being part of a community
but don't allow it to be your identity
your time the military is part of your
story but it's not your complete
identity As you move into the next
chapter offer yourself a Grace if you
find yourself struggling in certain
aspects wherever you'll go you'll always
be so take the most loving version of
yourself live a life of balance
compassion and love
and he writes everything on the planet
is meant to serve something other than
itself and humans aren't the exception
focus on loving and serving others over
being self-centered and things will work
out
when I ask you what your mission is
getting connected to your wife getting
connected to your kids getting connected
making new friends all of those things
are actions in service of a bigger
picture you do those things because
they're right and they're holy and
they're good but those are the only way
you can be a light in your community you
can do good work you can pave new
sidewalks for my kids that are coming up
behind yours right whatever the bigger
mission is and what you've got in your
head is a whole bunch of tasks
and we've got to come up with a bit with
a mission right where are we going to
serve what's that going to look like
we're all in service of something
what are we going to serve and then how
are we going to get to that service
um the other buddy she says
if you stay connected
you'll have so many resources available
to you that you can explore
she mentioned military one sources set
her up with a great civilian counselor
start unpacking stuff and repack all
that in a way that's healing to you
I would take advantage of the resources
I would also
tell those guys hey we're all I'm we're
going out I'm buying the first round no
military talk
call it out
and two or three of them are gonna go oh
thank God
and one or two would be like nah bro
this is are you giving up on and you'd
be like that's cool and that you just
know hey that's not gonna be one of my
guys that's fine
it's fine
how does that sound
it sounds good I mean it
it's
bro
it's no it's just uh
I don't know I guess I gotta get to that
part of going out with the guys type
thing man I'm just uh let's Dustin
Dustin you don't got to do anything
right now
foreign
you've been going for a decade
you've had your minute by minute planned
out for 10 years
people have shot at you
and now you're just going to work
give yourself a minute
uh my buddy Ian simkin says if if
busyness
is a drug
rest will feel like torture
does it ever
right and you've been busy
to keep you alive you've been busy doing
what other people told you to do for 10
years you just got to learn a new thing
man that's it
you've been a running back forever and
they just stuck you out wide receiver
you got to give yourself some Grace you
don't run past routes before just new
you're not broken or damaged or ruined
or an idiot or none of those things bad
guy gotta learn new stuff it's cool man
you're gonna trip and fall hit in the
head with a ball you're gonna drop a few
passes it's fine
has there ever been one thing that
you've had laid in front of you that you
just said I walked away from and said I
can't do this
never really been an option there you go
this one's not either
so all of this starts with with
um one big scary proposition
sit down your wife
and letting her know hey honey for the
first time in my life I'm scared like in
a real way
not scared someone's gonna shoot me I'm
scared that I don't know what comes next
and then I don't have the skills to move
forward
can we do this thing together because
we're going to build something totally
new
and I'm almost guaranteed she'll
probably weep with you and say I'm all
in is that you think so
okay
take a big deep breath as deep as you
can those big dust and lungs
and hold it
five four
three
exhale and drop your shoulders all the
way
down
you deserve sleep
rant bunch of sex with your wife
laughter with your kids paycheck a safe
home
and you're just going to learn new
skills are you in
definitely 100 yeah
my kids have their life because the guys
like you
so from guy to guy thank you
appreciate that
and that's not a platitude and that's
just that's not some little thing I'm
gonna put on a sign and post it on
Instagram that's me telling my brother
Dustin thank you
and I'll walk with you as much like can
you call me every show if you want we'll
just have Dustin section every show as
you figure this thing out because listen
you're you're you're one of the Brave
few because there's Millions walking
through this just like you
and they think they're crazy they think
it's their wife's gone mad and they
think that their husband's an idiot they
think that their kids are
and their bodies are screaming at them
hey we're alone we're not we're not safe
their bodies are screamed at them saying
we've got no mission
where are we going to serve next
and then we're gonna backfill that cool
definitely I love you man and I'm
grateful for you
thank you thank you thank you homework
assignment number one ask those
knuckleheads that you work with we're
going out we're all going out in not one
military conversation in fact I'm gonna
make it so weird for you
oh I can't this is I can't even think of
this I'm gonna make it super weird I'm
gonna send you a few questions for
humans packs and I know I know when you
pull them out those guys are going to
look at you as like you've just gotten a
fourth head
as though you were like hey you mind if
I like kiss all y'all's wives That's
Another gonna look at you and you're
gonna say nope we're doing this and it's
going to give you some Avenue however
much grief you're gonna take for it to
this Avenue
then they come up with a a pack for a
veterans man just to give them something
to talk about other than hey remember
the time
practice new skills how to have
conversations how to look into the
future instead of living that past
um stay on the line here Jenna's gonna
hook you up we'll give you I'll give you
a big a bunch of them
um and give you all something to talk
about
I'm proud of you and I'm grateful for
you my brother